I don't mean to interrupt but everyone
on the beach is talking about you guys
thank you well I just wanted to invite
all of you to the Huntley look I know
that the club's kind of fancy and
probably not your scene but you're never
standing in the teach thank you oh okay
hey Steph hey New Kids on the Block here
is from Iowa really let me ask you this
a lot of oceans in Iowa
no just ponds and lakes and hockey
pretty boys image what happened to that
last pretty boy recruit we have he died
what is this light third hazing Annette
Brodie hold the world record in the
200-meter road yes absolutely we still
[Music]
never really heard of guys sing that
song but they're really good thank you
by the way let me shower in here we huh
do you just look at my boobs I was not
my intention I didn't feel like right
now
now it did cuz we were talking about
testing up failed oh my god okay he just
like to thumb again
no it didn't I was
you never forget the one who steals your
heart or the one who kicks your ass some
[ __ ] [ __ ] is happening in our Beach
and my balls say we need to go over
there and check it out
is it badly damaged we're lifeguards my
balls say he's just thinking he's right
well my balls are saying [ __ ] that noise
let's go handle business your balls are
bullies hey watch works because we
follow rules Brody and not a single [ __ ]
was given is we're the best swimmers in
the whole world it's like if a human
[ __ ] a jetski which is impossible but
be so cool
[Music]
there's your cop don't jack off on my
sheets just remember I'm always watching
beyond teaching some manners
[Music]
All Things Considered things going to
get a lot worse
good that's good luck pick it up
[Music]
we need to search the morgue for
evidence check his tank for needle marks
the moment to check his taint lift his
[ __ ] scrotum and check his taint
dude it's a taint man it's attained
didn't even look get closer
oh holy yoghurt oh there's a hole that's
just his bottle of smile most of that do
not post that just a head full of ball
sack you turn the canals into the
goddamn X Games that's cuz we were in
lifeguard pursuit oh okay puppet except
for there's no [ __ ] such thing as
lifeguard pursuit
[Music]
you